[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى الخامسه من العربيه
والبدايه بابرز عناوين اليوم
قبيله ساعات من بدء هدنه السبعه ايام في
السودان اشتباكات متقطعه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع
واشنطن تستفز موسكو باعلانها عدم معارضه
قصف شبه جزيره القرن بطائرات اف 16
بعد اتهامه بعلاقه جاسوسيه الرئيس
الايراني يعفي شمخاني من رئاسه مجلس الامن
القومي الايراني
السلام عليكم من الفضاء والله شرف مره مره
كبير
قبل قليل المركبه دراغون تلتحم بمحطه
الفضاء الدوليه وترقب لنزول رواد
السعوديين
اهلا بكم الى ملفات الخامسه من العربيه
قبل ساعات من دخول الهدنه حيز التنفيذ
مساء اليوم شهدت العاصمه الخرطوم واجهات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع حيث افادت مصادر
خصل العربيه بان الجيش السوداني اطلق
قذائف مدفعيه ثقيله باتجاه مناطق تمركز
لقوات الدعم السريع بالخرطوم وياتي القصف
المدفعي مع تواصل اعمال العنف والمعارك في
انحاء العاصمه كما سمع دوي انفجارات في
مناطق متفرقه من بينها منطقه الصحافه
كلما اشتعلت نيران المواجهات المسلحه
هذا وارتفع عدد الضحايا من المدنيين في
الاشتباكات الدائره بالسودان الى
863 قتيلا والاصابات الى
351 اصابه وذكرت نقابه اطباء السودان في
تقريرها اليومي بشان الاشتباكات ان العديد
من الاصابات والوفيات غير مشموله في الحصر
بسبب صعوبه التنقل والوضع الامني الصعب في
البلاد
والان ننتقل مع حضراتكم على الهواء مباشره
الى نيويورك وهذه الجلسه لمجلس الامن
الدوليه حول الاوضاع في السودان
وعملا بالماده 39 من النظام الداخلي
المؤقت لمجلس الامن ادعو مقدمه الاحاطه
لاسمائهم الى المشاركه في هذا الاجتماع
السيد فولكر بيرتس الممثل الخاص للعميل
العام المعني بالسودان
ورئيس بعثه الامم المتحده المتكامله
لتقديم المساعده خلال الفتره الانتقاليه
في السودان
صاحب السعاده
وركنه
الامين التنفيذي للسلطه الحكوميه الدوليه
المعنيه بالتنميه تقرر ذلك
سيبدا مجلس الامن الان
النظر في البند الثاني من جدول العمل
اوجه عنايه اعضاء مجلس الامن الى الوثيقه
اس شهر 2023 شهرته 355
وهي تقرير الامين العام عن الحاله في
السودان وعن انشطه بعثه الامم المتحده
المتكامله لتقديم خلال الفتره الانتقاليه
في السودان
اعطي الكلمه الان للسيد بلكيس شكرا جزيلا
سيدتي ارى اذا الساده اعضاء مجلس الامن
مرت اكثر من قصه اسابيع منذ اندلاعي
القتال بين القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وقوات الدعم السريعه في السودان يوم
الخامس عشر من نيسان ابريل
قال رغم من اعلانات وقف اطلاق ينار
المتكرره السابقه من الطرفين لم نشهد يوما
بدون قتال ولم يستطع طرفه من الطرفين
اعلن انتصار حاسم على الطرف الاخر وهنا
الاتفاق على وقف اطلاق النار قصير المدى
والترتيبات الانسانيه والذي تم التوقيع
عليها منذ يومين في جده يعد خطوه هامه نحو
الامام ويعطي املا للمدنيين
ويظهر ان العنف يمكن ان ينتهي
اذا امتثل الطرفان
وساعود الى هذا في نهايه حديثي الموجز
المدنيون في السودان دفعوا بالفعل ثمنا
باهظا بسبب هذا العنف غير المبررات ووفقا
لتقديرات اكثر من 700 شخص قتلوا بما في
ذلك اكثر من 190 طفل
واصيب سته الاف اخرون من المدنيين
والكثيرون مفقودين واكثر من مليون تم
تشريدهم واكثر 840 الف
ساعه الى الريف او الى
واكثر او حوالي 250 الف
عبروا الحدود الى دول المجاوره وحوالي
8000 من المشردين من النساء الحوامل
يبحثون عن الامن والامن وكثيرون انتظروا
عند الحدود اياما واسابيع
وما من هذه الاحصاءات تظهر المعاناه
لكثيرين اخرين لم يستطيعوا الرحيل وبقوا
في ديارهم
بامدادات تنفذ وبدون الحصول على مساعدات
وانا ممتن للبلدان التي تستقبل اللاجئين
في السودان من السودان ومن الامر الحيوي
ان تبقى الحدود مفتوحه لمن يطلب الامان ان
الاجراءات عند الحدود
ينبغي ان يتم تعديلها ولون المتحده تواصل
توفير دعمها لتخفيف العبء على الدول
المجاوره ولضمان تلبيه احتياجات اللاجئين
بكرامه
سيدتي الرئيسه في الخرطوم وفي دارفور وفي
مناطق اخرى الاطراف المتناحره حاربوا
بمر محدوده للقوانين والمعايير المنازل
والمتاجر وبدور العباده
والمرافق الاساسيه من مياه وكهرباء تم
تدميرها وقطاع الصحه ينهار واكثر من ثلاثي
المستشفيات اغلقت وكثير من العاملين بمجال
الصحه قتلوا والامدادات الطبيه تنفذ وهناك
بلاغات متكرره عن استخدام مرافق الصحه كم
مواقع عسكريه وهذا غير مقبول وانا
ازازته بتقارير عنا العنف الجنسي ضد
المراه والفتاه بما في ذلك دعائه اغتصاب
في الخرطوم وفي دارفور والامم المتحده
تتابع للتحقق من هذه الحالات الاطراف
المتناحره ينبغي ان تمنع اي اعاده تكرار
لهذا العنف الاطفال يواجهون
مشاغل حمايه خطيره ويعرضون للتجنيد وللعنف
ضد الجنسيه وللاختطاف وهناك بلاغات متكرره
عن انتشار النهدي للمنازل للشركات
واستفزاز وتحرش
واختفاء القصريه
والمقرات الامميه بما في ذلك مجمع البعثه
تم النهبها كذلك
[موسيقى]
ومما يعقد المشهد اطلاق صلاحي الافي
السجناء وانتشار الاسلحه الخفيفه وما
يقلقني كذلك بلاغات عنا تهديد بقتل ضد
النشاطئ السياسيين والقيادات المدنيه
واعتقال المتطوعين واستفزاز صحفيين اصحاب
السعاده في بعض انحاء البلاد
القتال القتال بين الجيشين او التشكيلتين
المسلحتين ادى الى اندلاع
توتر قبلي واثني وفي الجنينه في غرب
دارفور الاشتباكات بين القوات المسلحه
السودانيه والقوات الدعم السريع تحولت الى
عنف اثني قبلي يوم 24 من ابريل
مش ميليشيات القبليه انضمت الى القتال
وحمل المدنيون السلاح للدفاع عن انفسهم
المنازل والاسواق
والمستشفيات حرقت ونهبت المقالات الامم
المتحده واكثر من نوعيه وخمسين مدني قتلوا
واكثر من 700 اصيبوا يوم الثاني عشر من
مايو تجدد العنف
وادى الى سقوط اكثر من 200 قتيل وعشرات
الالاف من المشاردين الذين فروا الى تشاد
والحاله
صعبه جدا وادعو واحث على التهدئه وهناك
اسباب قلق تتعلق بالبعد القبليه في جنوب
كردفان وفي منطقه النيل الازرق والقتال
ادى الى انتهاكات حقوق انسان خطيره
وانتهاكات القانون الانساني الدولي وقد
اضر بحمايه المدنيين وهذه الانتهاكات
ينبغي ان تخضع للتحقيق وينبغي للجناء ان
يقدموا للعداله
اسره المتحده تواصل المتابعه
والدعوه من اجل انهاء كل انتهاكات
سداد المجلس
بعض المعلقين
القوا اللوم
بسبب هذا النزاع على المجتمع الدولي لانه
لم يرى علامات الانذار واخرون القوا
باللوم على العمليه السياسيه او على
الاتفاق الاطاري والذي كان الغرض منه ان
يؤدي الى حكومه مدنيه او القى اللوم على
المجتمع الدولي بسبب
اعطائي دور كبير مفرط في حجمه للمسلحين
ولكن دعونا نبتغي الوضوح المسؤوليه عن
القتال تقع على اعتاق من يشن القتال يوميا
قيادات بالجانبين يتفقون في المساءله
والمسؤوليه بسبب اختيارهم حل النزاع
بالعنف بدلا من التفاوض القرار قرارهم
وقرار الانهاء بيديهم كذلك وما يحدث يوم
15 من ابريل ومنذ ذلك اليوم هو تحديدا
محاوله المتحده وحاول دولي ان يمنع حدوثه
قبل وبعد ال 25 من اكتوبر 2021
وتاريخ الانقلاب العسكري
تواصلنا
باهتمام وبنشاط مع القائدين العسكريين
وحاولنا اقناعهم
بدعم الحمليه الانتقاليه نحو القياده حكم
المدني ومع زياده التوتر اطلقت ناقوس
الخطر في هذا المجلس في اذار مارس هو
حثثته الاطراف على التهدئه وفي الاسبوعين
سابقين على اندلاع القتال انا وشركائي في
الالياف الثلاثيه
قمنا بتكثيف تواصلنا مع القيادات العسكريه
من اجل تهدئه الوضع وقمنا بتنسيق الجهود
مع القيادات المدنيه السودانيه وحاولنا
كذلك ان نتوسط بين
القيادات العسكريه واللوائين واقررت
بخطوره الموقف
وطلبت من الاطراف الاقليميه ان يستخدموا
نفوذهم مع الطرفين
واستمرت الجهود الى عشيه الخامس عشر من
ابريل حين ظننا اننا احرزنا تقدما
وانما استيقظنا وعلى واقع اختيار الحرب
سيدتي الرئيسه
للاسف الاعمال العدائيه تضطرنا
وتطردنا لان
ننقل موظفينا الى بورسودان والى خارج
السودان
وهذا ليس معناه وينبغي نكون واضحا جدا هنا
اننا تخلينا عن الشعب السوداني
اننا نواصل العمل مع الشركاء السودانيين
واننا ثابتون في التزامنا
باربعه اولويات فوريه اولا
توصل الى وقفه اطلاق نار مستقر باليه
ثانيا منع التصعيد او التحول القبلي لهذا
النزاع ثالثا حمايه المدنيين وتوفير
الاغاثه الانسانيه ورابعا الاستعداد
لعمليه سياسيه عندما يحين الوقت السليم
بمشاركه
واسعه من الجهات المدنيه والسياسيه بما في
ذلك النساء ومن خلال مركزنا في بورسودان
دعمت البعثه جهود الفريق القطري وشركاء
الانسانين من اجل استعاده تدفق الامدادات
الانسانيه الى داخل البلاد وفي انحاء
البلاد
وامم المتحده تبذل كلما تستطيع للتوسع في
استجابتنا في انحاء البلاد ولا سيما في
مناطق الاحتياج الحاد ولكن من الضروري
كذلك في شرق البلاد
عند البحر الاحمر وحيث بورتسودان
انه فيها شرق البلاد لا تستغل المنطقه فقط
كمدخل للمساعدات الانسانيه ولكن ان تحصل
من تقع على نصيبها كذلك المنصف من
الاحتياجات علما بلجوئي كثيرين الى هذه
المنطقه التمويل الاضافي مطلوب
والخط خطه الاستجابه الانسانيه المعدله
اطلقت في سبعه عشره من مايو ويصل يصل مبلغ
الى 2.6 مليار دولار للوصول الى 18 مليون
شخص وهي زياده 15 مليون دولار عن قبل
القتال
واصحاب السعاده بفضل الوساطه السعوديه
والامريكيه ممثل الطرفين وقعوا على
اعلاني التزاماتي في جده في يوم الحادي
عشر من عيار مايو وهو اتفاق على ترتيبات
عمل انساني هو وقف اطلاق نار قصير المدى
والمفترض ان تدخل حيز النفاذ الليله
وستبقى في الساريه لسبعه ايام وقابله
للتجديد والمفترض ان تسمح بتحرك المدنيين
وبوصول المساعدات
وهذا تطور حميد نرحب به
ولكن القتال استمر حتى اليوم على الرغم من
التعهد الطرفين بعدم محاوله احتياج
تفوق عسكري قبل دخول الاتفاقيه حيز نفاذ
بعثتنا مستعده لدعم اليه رصد على المدى
البعيد ومن اجل رصدي وقفه لقينار دائم
ويمكن ان نستند الى الهياكل التي انشات في
لجنه وقفه الاقنر الدائمه في دارفور والتي
تراسها البعثه واحث الاطراف على احترام
هذا الاتفاق الذي تم التوقيع عليه منذ
يومين
عليهما ان يوقف القتال وان يسمحوا بوصول
الاغاثه وان يحموا العاملين الانسانيين
والممتلكات الانسانيه وان يسمحوا بالمرور
الامن للمدنينه ليرحلوا عن مناطق الاشتباك
واحث قياده القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وقياده القوات الدعم السريع
على ضمان حمايه المدنيين
والمباني المدنيه اننا ننفق عن كثب مع
الشركاء السودانيين الذين يعملون من اجل
السلام واحيي كذلك قيادات الحركات المسلحه
على جهودهم لاستعاده السلام وعلى حيادهم
في هذا النزاع
المجتمع المدني السوداني يؤدي دورا قويا
في الدعوه من اجل السلام مع مواصله دعم
المدنيين هذه الجهود ينبغي ان تحظى بالدعم
والطرفان
يدعواني
لادانه الطرف الاخر
وادانه افعاله وانا ادعو الطرفين الى
انهاء القتال والعوده الى الحوار لمصلحه
السودان وشعب السودان
الارواح والمباني تدمرت والبنيه تحتيه
تدمرت والبعد القبلي المتزايد لهذا النزاع
ابن يهدد
بطول النزاع وبتدعيات على المنطقه وان
وقفه النار المتفق عليه يمكن له ان يمهد
الطريق وينبغي ان يفعل ذلك من اجل وقف
دائم للاعمال العدائيه
ومع تقدم المباحثات فهناك طائفه واسعه من
الجهات المدنيه والسياسيه التي ينبغي ان
تؤدي دورها وفي نهايه المطاف ليست الا
مرحله انتقاليه بقياده مدنيه ذات مصداقيه
هي التي سترسم طريق السلام الدائم
نائب مجلس السياده
النص على ان اولويته هي وقف اطلاق النار
وانهاء الحرب واسكاتي المدافع وهذا بلا شك
يستحق دعمنا ودعمكم الكامل
الجهود الاقليميه والدوليه لانهاء القتال
في السودان تستحق الحمد وبعد تضاعف هذه
الجهود ينبغي ان نضمن التنسيق من اجل
تحديد نهج مشترك هذا سينهض
بتاثيرنا الجماعي وفعاليه الجهود اي خطه
منسقه ينبغي ان يشارك فيها جيران السودان
في المنطقه وانا مسرور جدا انا زميلائي
المفوض بنكولي والامين التنفيذي دكتور
بورد
سيتحدثان وسيدخلاني في التفاصيل بشان جهود
الاليه الثلاثيه
وستواصل المتحده للعمل الوثيق مع الشركاء
في اطار هذه الاليه ثلاثيه وهما الاتحاد
الافريقي والهيئه الدوليه المعنيه
بالتنميه لايجاد دعما لهذه الجهود والجهود
الاخرين وشكرا
اشكركم على الاحاطه الكلمه الان
للسيد بنكولي
طب انا ما حضراتكم هذا الجزء من كلمه
المبعوث الامميه الى السودان والذي اشار
بشكل واضح ان القتال منذ اليوم الاول وحتى
اللحظه لم يتوقف ويدعو كافه الاطراف الى
ضروره الالتزام باتفاق او اعلان جدا لوقف
اطلاق النار حتى يكون هناك هدنه حقيقيه
تسمح بالمساعدات الانسانيه اعلن وزير
الخارجيه النمساوي
ان سلطات بلاده تحتفظ بقنوات اتصال غير
رسميه مع روسيا مؤيدا بذلك استمرار الحوار
مع موسكو على الرغم من استمرار الصراع في
اوكرانيا كما قال ان على الغرب مواصله
الحوار مع روسيا خصوصا انها اكبر قوه
ناويه على الارض
قالت التفاعل البريطانيه ان روسيا بدات
تشكيل قوه نخبه جويه هجوميه لدعم المعارك
على الارض في اوكرانيا افادت في احدث
تقييم استخباراتي بان هذه القوات تدعى
ومدعومه بمقاتلات سيخوي 24 وسوخوي 34
ومروحيات هجوميه قتاليه الدفاع البريطانيه
اشارت ايضا ان روسيا تستقطب الان طيارين
عسكريين ذو خبرات كبيره لضمهم لفرقه
النخبه الجديده
من موسكو تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه
الزميله مرحبا بك كاتيا هناك تساؤلات حول
التغير في الاستراتيجيات الدفاعيه او
العسكريه من قبل موسكو للتعامل مع الحرب
في اوكرانيا ما الذي يعنيه هذه الخطه
الجديده بضم نخب جديده من طيارين عسكريين
يتمتعون بكفاءه كبيره هل هذا يعني
الاعتماد على الهجوم الجوي
مرحبا رشا طبعا روسيا الان وبعد ان تمت
السيطره على مدينه باكموت من قبل قبل قوات
فارغ الخاصه هي روسيا كانت الان في هي في
حاله ترقب لان يكون هناك هجوم مضاد من قبل
اوكرانيا وبالاخص بعد الاعلان المستمر
الذي كان ياتي من قبل تقارير غربيه بانه
سيكون هناك هجوم مضاد من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه لذلك هي بالاخص وفقا لهذه
واستنادا على هذه التقارير الاخيره بانها
تقوم بتجهيز خبراء طيران يقول خبراء
عسكريين بانها الان تستعد لصد هذه الهجوم
او الهجوم المتوقع من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه وبالاخص في ضوء امكانيه تزويد
اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف 16 وهذا ما علق عليه
طبعا اولا سفير الروسي في لدى وعاشتون
الذي تحدث عن ان هذه الخطوه هي خطوه
تصعيديه اول وان الهجوم على القرن بالاخص
بعد تهديدات او سماح واشنطن لاوكرانيا
بهجوم على شبه جزيره القرم هو يعد بالنسبه
لموسكو استهداف اراضي روسيه ولكن هو كما
ايضا مؤكد ان اوكرانيا ليس لديها القاعده
العسكريه التي تساعد او تساعدها على
استخدام هذه الطائرات في حصولها على
مقاتلات اف 16 من قبل واشنطن او الغرب
وبالتالي روسيا الان كما تحدثتي
رشا ان هي تقوم طبعا
الاستعداد في حال ان يكون هناك هجوم مضاد
من قبل قوات الاوكرانيه اولا قد تقوم
بمهاجمتهم طبعا باستخدام هذه الطائرات
وباستخدام هذه القوات القوات محموله جوا
وهي بالاساس تعتمد كثيرا خلال عمليه
العسكريه على الاسلحه العاليه الدقه
لقصفها او في قصفها المستودع ات الاسلحه
في الاراضي الاوكرانيه او البنيه التحتيه
هناك رشا شكرا لك كاتي اطعمه مراسله
العربيه من موسكو على كل هذه المعلومات
زميلتي كانت شكرا
بعد اعلان روسيا السيطره على ضخمه
الاوكرانيه اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
انها تتقدم في محيط بخموت لكن كثافه
العمليات العسكريه تراجعت المسؤول الموالي
لموسكو بمقاطعه
اكد ان عمليه تنظيف المدينه من الالغام قد
بدات من اجل دخول مؤسسات الدوله اليها
واضاف بوشليم بان الجيش الروسي يواصل
التقدم لسيطره على مدن اوكرانيه اخرى
من جانبه اعلن قائد مجموعه عن انسحاب قوته
من مدينه بخموت وتسليمها للقوات الروسيه
بحلول الاول من يونيو بعد اعلانه السيطره
التامه عليها وقال يبكيني بيرجين انه في
حال عدم وجود عدد كافي من القوات الروسيه
في ضخمه يجب تشكيله فوج من الضباط وتقديم
السلاح لهم لسيطره على المدينه
في سياق اخر اعلنت الشركه الوطنيه
الاوكرانيه المشغله لمحطه زبروجيا النوويه
اعاده التيار الكهربائي من خط الطاقه
الخارجي بعد انقطاع عندما لفتره وجيزه
تبعه اعلان حاله الطوارئ هذا واوضحت
الشركه المشغله ان محطه النوويه لا تزال
حتى اليوم مربوطه بنظام الطاقه الاوكرانيه
ولا طالما اصرت الولايات المتحده على ان
شبه جزيره القرم لا تزال جزءا لا يتجزا من
اوكرانيا ورغم الموقف الامريكي الصريح
بشان تبعيه القرم لكييف لكن تزويدها بسلاح
كاف قد يمكن اوكرانيا من استعاده شبه
جزيره القرم كما يتوقع البعض وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه كان شدد في مطلع العام
على ان بلاده لا تشجع اوكرانيا على بسط
نفوذها على الارض التي خسرتها بالطبع
لصالح روسيا في 2014 الا انه وفي تصريحات
اخيره للبيت الابيض تشير الى تغير كلي في
الموقف الامريكي للمره الاولى حيث اكد
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيكس سولفا
ان واشنطن لا تمانع شن اوكرانيا لهجمات
على شبه جزيره القرد باسلحه امريكيه صلب
قال في مقابله مع شبكه سي ان ان الاخباريه
الامريكيه ان بلاده لا تضعوا اي قيود في
وجه اوكرانيا لاستهداف الاراضي الواقعه
داخل حدودها والمعترف بها دوليا معتبرا ان
شبه جزيره القرم ارضا اوكرانيه محتله وقفه
وقفه توصيفي تصريحاته جاءت عاقبه تزويد
كيات بطائرات اف 16 لاول مره فيما لا تزال
واشنطن لا تدعم شن هجمات اوكرانيه
باستخدام اسلحه النيتو في العمق الروسي
من جهته حضر سفير روسيا لدى الولايات
المتحده انطوني انتينوف حضر واشنطن من
خطوره حصول اوكرانيا على مقاتلات اف 16
مؤكدا ان استخدامها في هجمات على شبه
جزيره القرم سيعيد اعتداء او سيعد اعتداء
على روسيا السفير الروسيه اكد نيه
الولايات المتحده لان تكون على درايه
كامله بالرد الروسي على اي هجوم اوكراني
محتمل
من جهته اكد مفوض شؤون الخارجيه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيفوريل ان عمليات تدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين على مقاتلات اف 16
بدات والباب اصبح مفتوحا لارسالها الى
كييف كما قال اليوم من بروكسيل
الدبلوماسيه السابقه الكسندر بسكين مرحبا
بك معنا سيد الكسندر يبدو اننا امام تطور
عسكري جديد الى حد كبير امريكا التي كانت
تمانع استخدام 16 في القرن يبدو انها تعطي
الضوء الاخضر لاوكرانيا للقيام بهذه
الخطوه كيف ستتعامل روسيا مع هذا التطور
اظن التطور كان متوقع رغم غموض التصريخات
السابقه الامريكيه ولكن من الواضح انه
الغرب الى امريكا يتوجه الى تقديم وزير
ومجيد والمزيد من السلاح
ومتنوع الى اوكرانيا بما في ذلك طبعا
طائرات قرش ما هو الجواب الروسي وتصريحات
السياسيه الاخيره
لنايب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
في امريكا اي تصريحات سياسيه الدول على
انه يجب الله ان ياخذ شان الاعتبار الجميل
بما في ذلك الامريكان ان الكرم
من روسيا اما الجواب العسكري طبعا هذا
يتعلق بالقياد العسكري وقائد العام فلذلك
سابق لا ان نتحدث حول هذا الموضوع
جدير بالذكر انه
صحيح ندخل مرحله جديده بعض الاشتلاء على
محمود
وربما يكون هناك
هجوم مضاد وليش بكون على روسيا
جاهزه لرد على هذا الهجوم وبما في ذلك
التامين التفوق
في الاجواء ورغم انه صوره غامضه بنسبه
اف 16 اين اعطينا المطارات وكيف بتصير
صيانه ولكن في كل الاحوال يبدو ان هناك
القرارات متخصصه عسكريه
من الجانب الروسي لتامين التفاوض
هذا هو الواقع الان
بخبرتك الدبلوماسيه هل يمكن ان يكون هذا
التصعيد والفتح لجبهات الجديده يمكن ان
تواجه فيها موسكو معارك عسكريه جديده هو
نوع من التصعيد الذي يمكن ان تعقبه تهدئه
بمعنى انه قد يكون مؤشر على
هدنه ماء او تهدئه ما في النصف الاخير من
هذا العام كما يتوقع البعض
لا اتوقع ذلك والخصم العسكري هو الخيار
القائمه الان ما فيش هناك ايه مؤشرات
الى اكتمال العودنا وانتقال للتفاوض لانه
المواقف الاطراف المعنيه الاساسيه
الامريكان اداره بايدن خيار ثابت انه
استمرار المعركه
ونظام كيف نفس الموقف وطبعا الروسيه
ورسميه جاهزه للتفاوت ولكن الله هناك
الشروط يبدو شروط
لا يمكن
[موسيقى]
للنظام كيف يقبلها فبالتالي ان هناك تناقض
واضح في المواقف
وما فيش اكتمال لتفاوض السفير الكسن در
السفير والدبلوماسيه السابق من موسكو شكرا
لك
ونبقى معكم مشاهدينا في ملفات الخامسه
ولدينا
بعد اتهامه بعلاقه جاسوسيه الرئيس
الايراني يعفي شمخان من رئاسه مجلس الامن
القومي الايراني
الخامسه متواصله مع حضراتكم من العربيه
قالت وكاله تسنيم للانباء الايرانيه شبه
الرسميه ان الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي
قرر تعيين علي اكبر احمد يان امينه العام
لمجلس الامن القومي خلفا لعلي شمخاني جاء
ذلك في مرسوم صادر عن الرئيس ابراهيم
رئيسي والذي استبدل به شمخاني عقب سلطه
بجاسوس ايراني مزعوم يحمل الجنسيه
البريطانيه ايضا واعدمته سلطات مؤخرا وشغل
احمد يان سابقا منصب رئيس الاركان
المشتركه للحركه الثوري وتولى ايضا رئاسه
المركز الاستراتيجي للحرس منذ عام 2006
علي اكبر احمدان
الامين العام الجديد للمجلس الاعلى للامن
القومي الايراني كان قائدا للقوات البحريه
للحرس الثوري الايراني من عام
1997 الى عام 2000 تراس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه للحرس الثوري الايراني بين عامي
2006 تراس المركز الاستراتيجيه للحرس
الثوري الايراني منذ عام 2006 ويعد عضوا
بارزا في مجمع تشخيص مصلحه النظام
وانضم الينا من الرياضه الباحث في الشان
الايرانيه صالح حميد مرحبا بك استاذ صالح
هذا القرار من الرئيس الايراني هل يعني
انه اعتراض بان ثمه اختراق كبير قد تم
للاجهزه الامنيه الايرانيه
تحياتي لك استاذه رشاد المشاهدين الكرام
يعني قد لا يكون الامر مرتبط بشكل مباشر
بقضيه اكبر لانه هي احدى القضايا التي
اثيرت ضد شمخاني من
التيار الاصولي المتشدد الحقيقه هذا
التيار وعلى راسه جبهه الصمود احد مكونه
هذا التيار التي
يعني تسيطر الان على مفاصل الدوله على
الحكومه على البرلمان تريد ايضا السيطره
على باقي المؤسسات المتبقيه منها المجلس
الاعلى الامن القومي
مطالبه ايضا باستبدال رئيس المجلس الاعلى
للثوره الثقافيه وقام المرشد الاعلى بذلك
وايضا تطالب
باستبدال الرئيس المجلس الاعلى السيبراني
واستبداله ايضا بشخصيه منهم انا اعتقد هذا
التغيير ياتي في اطار صراع الاجنحه لانه
شنقاني محسوب على الاصلاحيين ايضا القضيه
التي اثير ضده من قبل متشددين من خلال
الاحتجاجات الاخيره عندما ذهب والتقى ببعض
الاصلاحين ودعاهم الى الشارع الحوار مع
الشعب المشاركه في تهدئه الاوضاع ولكن هذه
الامور كانت موجوده منذ فتره طويله كما
نعلم استاذ صالح فكره استبدال مع الحركه
الثوري او المتشددين بالاصلاحيين ولكن
التوقيت الكلي يتساءل لماذا الان
نعم هذا سؤال مهم لماذا الان لانه
شمخاني بعدما دار المفاوضات التي افضت الى
اتفاق مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
واكسبت ايران الكثير من الامتيازات
اصبح له رصيدا سياسيا كبيرا
وكما نعلم يعني المرشد الايراني علي خانني
يقوم
بتهميش كل شخصيه يصبح لها وزنا سياسيا
بهذا الحجم يعني المثال هو الرئيس السابق
حسن روحاني الذي ابرم الاتفاق النووي
وايضا اكسب النظام والبلاد لامتيازات
كثيره بما فيها رفع العقوبات لكن بعد ذلك
يعني تم
ابعاد اي وجوه اصلاحيه يمكن ان تكون لها
شعبيه تمهيدا لشيء ما
لا هو في اطار يعني
القبضه الحديديه للتيار المتشدد كما نعلم
في هذه في هذا الملف مثلا الملف التفاوض
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه كان لشام
خالد دور الاكبر ليس للحكومه لان عبد الله
الوزير الخارجيه ليس كما الخرازي رئيس
المجلس الاستراتيجي العلاقات الخارجيه
ايضا مفاوضات كانت هناك مع الصين دار
هاشمخاني مفاوضات مع روسيا
وبتفويض بالطبع من المرشد لكن الان هذا
الدور الذي هذا الرصيد السياسي الكبير
الذي كسبه شنقانه بعد ابرام الاتفاق مع
السعوديه انا برايي هو الذي دفع الى هذا
استطاع الفصوليا من خلاله اقناع المرشد
بدفعه الى الاستقاله واستبداله
باللواء احمد وهو شخصيه محسوبه على فريق
القدس وقريب من المتشددين الاستاذ صالح
حميد الباحثه في شان الايرانيه من الرياض
تحياتي
احتفت وزاره الحج والعمره باول دفعه حجاج
وصلوا الى مكه المكرمه وواصلت الدفعه
الاولى من الحجاج من بنجلاديش الى مطار
الملك عبد العزيز بجده قبل الذهاب الى مكه
وبلغ عدد الحجاج الذين وصلوا الى مكه حتى
يوم امس اكثر من 800 حج
[موسيقى]
هكذا استقبلت مكه المكرمه اولى طلائع
الحجاج في الاهازيج الفرائحيه وكذلك
الاستقبال
والسرور الذي امتلا في هذه الاركان
لاستقبال اولى طلائع الحجاج في عام 20 23
حيث استقبلت مركز النواريه ولا طلائع
الحجاج عبر عشره حافلات صباحا وعشره
حافلات مساء سيكون العدد حتى المساء اليوم
الذين دخلوا الى مكه استعدادا للحج ولو
كان مبكرا قبل شهر ونصف اكثر من 500 حاج
قدموا ووصلوا الى مكه المكرمه عبر السلسله
من الخدمات بدات من مطار الملك عبد العزيز
في جده في امتدادا الى هذا المركز ودخولا
الى داخل مكه المكرمه اشاهد عدد من
المسؤولين الذين يستقبلون الحجاج مسؤولين
وزاره الحج والعمره الذي نستقبلوا الحجاج
بالورود وبالهدايا
ولعمل الضيافه لهم قبل دخولهم الى مكه
المكرمه استعدادا لاداء المناسك بعد شهر
ونصف الشهر من الان
[موسيقى]
نحن بنحاول قدر المستطاع انه الفتره اللي
يقضيها الحاج من اول وصوله الى المطار حتى
وصوله الى مكان سكنه ما يكون فيها اي مجال
انتصار فيكون كلها مسبقه التحضير يعني
الان الحبلتين الان استقبلناه قبل دقائق
كان جميع بيانات الحجاج كانت مرتده من قبل
48 ساعه عارفين بالضبط فين ساكنين مجرد
وصفه وصولهم حتى وقائمه الحجاج تاتي بشكل
مباشر طريقه الكترونيه
[موسيقى]
هؤلاء الحجاج قطعوا مسافه كبيره ومن اجل
هذه المسافه ومن اجل ان لا يكون هنالك
اجهاد عليهم يعمل المسؤولون في وزاره الحج
وكذلك كافه الجهات السعوديه على تسهيل
اجراءاتهم حيث قبل ان يقلعوا من بلادهم
بنغلاديش تم تسهيل اجراءاتهم عبر مبادره
الطريق الى مكه وهنا عمليه انتظارهم لا
تستغرق وقتا طويلا حتى يدخل الى داخل مكه
المكرمه استعدادا للقيام بالعمره وكذلك
الحج قبل شهر كامل منه على ان تتوالى
عمليات الاستقبال خلال الايام القادمه مع
وصول اول طلائع الحجاج عبد المحسن الحربي
العربيه مكه المكرمه
والخامسه مستمره على شاشه العربيه بعد هذا
الفصل
بعد اكثر من 16 ساعه من التحليق في الفضاء
اكتملت مناوره الالتحام للمركبه دراجون
التي تحمل رائدي الفضاء السعوديين ريان
برناوي وعلي القرني واكتملت مناوره
التحامها مع محطه الفضاء الدوليه المركبه
دراجون انطلقت بعد منتصف ليل امس من مركز
كينيدي الفضائي في فلوريدا بمهمه فضائيه
يشارك بها ايضا فضاء اخرين من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
الحمد لله
الحمد لله على اللحظه التاريخيه لنعيشها
ما هو بس انا اعيشها احنا وانتم سويه
استمتعنا صراحه بالاطلاق ولم تاكد انكم
انتم
المشاهده
شكرا شكرا لكل من دعمنا شكرا كل ما نوقف
معنا وساعدنا شكرا لمن وصلنا لهذه المرحله
شكرا لسموخ سيدي خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز شكرا لولي عهده
الامير محمد بن سلمان على هذا الدعم
والتمكين والثقه فينا كشباب طموحين برغبه
بلهفه بان ان ان نح
قق وتوفيقكم اهلي انا في الفضاء الحلم
تحقق اللهم لك
الحمد قريبا ان شاء الله في المستقبل
القريب الكثير سوف ينضم لنا ان شاء الله
ونراكم قريبا من محطه الفضاء الدوليه
احب ابدا الشكر بقيادتنا
صاحب الرؤيه ولي عهدنا محمد بن سلمان على
دعم ولا هذه المهمه شكرا للهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء شكرا اكسيوم شكرا شكرا
على تدريبهم لنا طبعا شكرا لست لعائلتي
الجميله واصحابي ورواد الفضاء السعوديين
علي الغامدي ومريم فردوس على دعمهم فهذه
الرحله
لابناء الوطن الغالي نحن الان في عصر
التمكين والازدهار بفضل الله ثم قيادتنا
الحمد لله نحن الان وصلنا عنان السماء
فكلنا نحتاج نسوي ونحلم باذن الله ونشتغل
على احلامنا وباذن الله راح نوصل
في مهرجان كان سينمائيه تعد الخيمه
السعوديه ملتقى للسينمائيين وصناع الافلام
الذين ناقشوا في ندوات النوعيه صناعه
الافلام وتسهيلات الكبيره لتصوير الافلام
الكبيره في العلا ونيوم التفاصيل مع زميل
سعد المسعودي
الخيمه السعوديه باتت ملتقى السينمائيين
وصناع السينما من كل انحاء العالم حيث
تشهد هذه الخيمه حوارات مفتوحه وندوات
متخصصه وقد اشادت اداره مهرجان كان
السينمائي بدعم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وببرنامجها الدائم لسينما الشباب بالتاكيد
نحن نعرف ان العديد من الدول ومنذ فتره
طويله تعمل على دعم السينما في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والتي تقوم بدعم الشباب
وتجاربهم السينمائيه
الصندوق الثقافي اطلق برنامج الاستثمار في
قطاع الافلام بميزانيه تبلغ 300 مليون
ريال سعودي ضمن مبادره تمويل القطاع
الافلام والتي يبلغ اجمالي ميزانيتها نحو
879 مليون ريال سعودي وهي احدى مبادرات
برنامج المحتوى الرقمي كما نظمت فيلم
العلا برنامج العلا لتطوير المواهب فيما
يقوم الجناح السعودي بالتعريف بمواقع
التصوير لافلام الهوليديه الكبرى في
نيويورك وبعض المناطق التاريخيه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بشكل عام اصبح الايه يلتفت بشكل اوضح
واكثر جديه للجناح السعودي الذي منذ
انطلقنا وهو مزدحم كما ترون واعتقد ان اسم
المبنى السعوديه وجناح اصبح اسما صعبا لا
يمر بسهوله واصبحت خيمه العرب هذه الانظار
في اين محلت ونظمت هيئه الافلام عده
حوارات مفتوحه عن مختلف الاختصاصات
السينمائيه وعن كيفيه القيام بتصوير
وانتاج فيلم في السعوديه بمشاركه نخبه من
المختصين في السينما ومخرجين من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وندوات عن جذب الاستثمار
في قطاع السينما كما يشارك مهرجان البحر
الاحمر وشركه
واثراء ووزاره الاستثمار ووفد من المخرجين
والمواهب السعوديه ويقدمون يوميا نشاطا عن
مستقبل صناعه السينما في السعوديه خليه
عمل سينمائيه يوميه يشهدها هذا الجناح
السعودي في مهرجان كان السينمائي ندوات
وحوارات مفتوحه لمختلف الاختصاصات
السينمائيه وتوقيع اتفاقات لتبادل الخبرات
هو جانب الاستثمارات السينمائيه سعد
المسعودي العربيه مهرجان كان سينمائي
كان هذا ختام الخامس من العربيه نلقاكم
على خير الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات